in psychology projection is displacing
your feelings onto someone else and in
politics or colloquially we sometimes
call projection
when you blame others for doing
something which actually you are the one
who is guilty of doing and it's very
hard to imagine any better example of
that in the modern political landscape
than republicans obsessing about
supposed democratic voter fraud voter
impersonation and other hijinks when it
is actually anecdotally they themselves
that are doing it even though overall
it's extraordinarily rare we now have
another example of this as a republican
has pleaded guilty to voting in two
different states and again the big
picture story is that this type of thing
is very rare
not very easy to do
and has never impacted any election to
the degree that it would actually affect
the results at the micro level when
individual instances of voter fraud
actually take place it's almost
exclusively republicans who are actually
doing it sometimes to quote test the
system they claim
uh or listen i killed him just to see if
the police are that good at solving
murders give me a break okay
and sometimes it is because they are
actually trying to do it
they just want to vote twice or whatever
the case may be in this article we have
learned of a new hampshire republican
who voted in two states
a man who voted in both new hampshire
and massachusetts in the 2016 general
election has been ordered to pay nearly
five thousand dollars in fines and
penalties
now i think it's also important to
mention that sometimes when people have
accidentally voted illegally they get
prison time there's a famous story of a
black woman who um
wasn't even deliberately voting multiple
times she just wasn't supposed to vote
and she did
she went to jail
in this case todd kriziak
is having to pay a five thousand dollar
fine
was charged in june of 2019 pleaded
guilty friday to vote voting in more
than one state he was given a 90-day
suspended sentence a four thousand
dollar fine and a roughly thousand
dollar penalty he cast ballots in alton
new hampshire
and leominster massachusetts on election
day of 2016. kriziac was registered as a
republican in alton attorney david
bedanza said his client voted in alton
where he lives
later visited in mother in massachusetts
she said hey
your name's on the list here
where he previously lived so he went
there and voted as well he went down to
vote thinking that he could
does anyone believe that is there any
adult you know we had this story after
the um in november there was the
virginia gubernatorial election where
glenn younkin won defeated terry
mcauliffe and we learned that his 17
young 17 year old kid
went and tried to vote i believe it was
twice but at least tried to vote once
and he was turned away because he's not
18 years old
and later
glenn youngen chalked it up to he didn't
know he couldn't vote he thought you
know he might be able to vote
is it believable that there's any 17
year old in this country i'm not talking
about someone you know from from someone
who's been kept out of school and has
never watched tv and but just like a
normal upper middle class 17 year old
who goes to a good school
that doesn't know you have to be 18 to
vote it's just not believable this is
even less believable i thought i could
vote in both places i thought i could
vote twice
what
um
that doesn't make any sense even weirder
is that bodanza called the plea a fair
resolution but said the case raised
unanswered questions about whether
krissyak acted knowingly in regard to
each element of the crime he said his
client didn't intend to vote in
massachusetts when he voted in new
hampshire so that and understand just
the bizarre nature of that he said he
thought he could vote twice when he went
to vote in new hampshire at that point
he wasn't thinking i'll also vote in
massachusetts so the new hampshire vote
wasn't fraudulent it wasn't part of
planning to vote twice
his mom gave him the idea by saying you
know i saw you're still registered in
massachusetts as well and so then he
said well i'll go and vote oh so it's
not as bad because when you went to new
hampshire it wasn't part of give me a
break guys now i think it's very
important to to issue one other uh
reminder here
we on the left who care about facts
should
distinguish from between
when they lie
versus when they tell the truth about
something that's not actually a problem
so what do i mean by that
they would spread the lie after 2020.
tons of dead people voted
okay well no actually
dead people didn't vote what they often
mean by that is
a live people go and they say my name is
such and such and it's the name of a
dead person and they vote in that
person's name number one that hasn't
happened number two it's a really bad
way to win an election because there's
not so many of those people that you
could actually in a reasonable way flip
an election there's just not enough
hours in the day on election day however
it sometimes happens
that
someone fills out and sends in an
absentee ballot
legally they're alive
then they die before election day
okay
that is a clerical issue
they've not done anything against the
law they were alive when they sent in
their absentee ballot here's another
example
people voted twice well when sometimes
people actually vote twice
we find out it's a republican and we
found it recently with some trump
supporters down in the villages in
florida we found it with this guy
however sometimes what they mean is hey
we found someone who's registered in two
places that's not a crime that's a
clerical issue as long as you only vote
in one place it's not a big deal when i
moved to new york from massachusetts
there was a period of time
where i was still registered in
massachusetts
and then i went and i signed up to vote
in new york
uh no problem i was registered twice for
a period of time i didn't vote in both
places i didn't do anything wrong
tiffany trump trump's daughter exact
same situation
um
so let's distinguish between things that
they say are happening that aren't
and things that they say are happening
that are happening but aren't actually a
problem it's not illegal it's not
against the law there's no crime there's
no wrongdoing a lot of these are just
clerical issues this guy voted twice
knowingly he's paying a five thousand
dollar fine